do you do that so you take drugs yeah
dude yeah
Escape in reality do you what's your
what's your drug of choice I mean weed's
not even a drug anymore I'm a mushroom
guy getting into acid a little bit late
lately went to see Roger Waters on acid
wow yeah
um blew my mind Roger met him on acid
it's trying to have a conversation is he
an anti-semite no because that's also a
rumor is that a rumor like a it's a
narrative that gets going he's
anti-suffering
that's it he sees him suffering and he's
like that seems wrong right he's not
interested it's my favorite album of all
time is dark side of the moon it's so
good but but um so you you uh take acid
now when's the first time you took acid
I took I taken it here that took an
ember one you took it here I took it
here or there oh okay yeah okay
um are you are you stoned now no I do
get people asking if I'm high when I'm
not high usually I get right but I'm not
and then I'm fine and normal uh I took
some Ayahuasca in the in the in the in
the jungle that was a like another level
of it but for mental health reasons
so do for your clean out your insides
yeah did it work yeah do you think
do you think that's it it changed his
life
um I could believe that no one doesn't
have really cathartic experiences on it
so you take acid and uh well mostly just
go to concerts have a good time
you know enjoy your life so Roger Waters
you got to talk to him what was that
like first of all I was bawling crying
next to some old lady in the stands like
like openly weeping and she's looking at
me and I'm like first a little
embarrassed and I'm like you [ __ ] saw
this guy in the 70s you know what the
[ __ ] happening she gotta shut up with
your [ __ ] judging eyes
um
yeah he's such an intense dude wait why
how did you get to meet him for Rogan I
shouldn't have oh I think I said did you
guys go out to dinner after a drink it
was just like after party and I showed
up there that Rogan's like we got to
leave for the last song and I was like
you can go [ __ ] yourself this is the
best concert I've ever been to I'm not
leaving and he goes dude you're on acid
in a strange city and I was like Joe
I've been on heavy drugs in lots of
places around the world I'll be fine
I'll meet up with you
um and if I don't I don't and I did and
then we're just all talking me and my
friend Tony's girlfriend also on acid
we're trying to keep it together they're
like showing like uh cell phones like
look at this Meme and I'm like and I
told my friend Duncan I was like is this
a video and he's like no I'm like
it's still [ __ ] kicking I went to the
[ __ ] airport at 5 30 in the morning
I'm looking at the departures gate
asking a guy like does this video keep
flipping and he's like what video and
I'm like [ __ ]
um it was good acid dude uh yeah I'm
trying to hold together a conversation
have you ever had a bad trip no no
no no I've been it's it's been a little
too much it was a Glastonbury everything
was like too much for me like heavy
mushrooms customers a music festival no
what does that mean it's too much it was
just too many people I had to be alone
mushrooms will look out for you I don't
I can't say the same about acid but
mushrooms will take care of you they'll
hold you by the hand and they'll take
care of you
too many people somebody recognized me I
was starting a trip here okay and then
I'm trying to dance I'm like somebody's
looking at me I want them looking at me
I just want to be anonymous I had to
wander away from my group and couldn't
find anywhere to try to be anonymous but
yet you're dancing alone I was with
people oh okay yeah it was a 200 000
person Festival Oh I thought and I
wandered away and I'm trying to find a
place where I can just lay down and be
alone in my thoughts and then mushrooms
just gave me a teepee somewhere
and I just like saw a little sign says
if you need to take a load off come on
in you found a teepee yeah and I just go
into this tip and there's all these
blankets and pillows there and it's just
lay in the darkness listening to the
music and the sound of people out there
do you believe that really happened that
you found the TP with blankets yeah it
happened
it happened well you also thought The
departure gate was a video yeah so how
do you know the TP and the blankets were
real I mean you may be maybe maybe
you're right and you believe it's the
mushrooms the mushrooms provided me yeah
maybe but it wasn't your teepee it was
not my TP but there was a sign there it
said it's here for you if you need it
and I did need it like bathrooms this
way and you wandered into the bathroom I
laid there for about an hour hour and a
half until I got other people in the TP
somebody eventually came in and was like
what the [ __ ] what is this place and he
laid down but he was like I was way in
the back and it was like anybody here I
was just quiet and he went away after
like 10 minutes
and then eventually I got I got my
wherewithal and I went back out to the
festival met up with my friends that's a
weird story it was so weird is there
anything that you won't try
I know I'm a little scared of powder now
because of fentanyl yeah you you um you
gotta test your [ __ ] everybody test your
[ __ ] don't not do drugs test your [ __ ]
yeah it's more of a PSA than a podcast
[Music]